зроблено в Україні
український молочної піни фаршу проходьте
європе рівер коала реальних поставок
доки травня дозрів на експорт видають не
тільки я все обладнання вигляд побачу
європейським стандартам головне який
зірвані топ то самого молока 80
відсотків українці молока це хвилин 52
сотки молока в українець і так званій
фермерські селянський бабусі
а все менше цифер мікки шанують створі
ось якщо охоловши фірмі киснути ecs можна
було б назвати довідковими фірмами до
бізнесу та д-да якісь молока особі
vortice молока деза курми ми здобути та
бризок убиті рамами стежать за коровами
стежать їх порядку п'яти
молока екстра-клас узбекова за євро
стандартам та роблять молочну продукцію
вага в україні лиж знову ж сотки в
оцінювати експерти, перераховуючи кисть
можна внесок шоу фірми властивості молока
мельоні інвестиції
однак ланцюг від вишити та vortice
української продукції який же за раз вищий
європейської
за 1 євро паспарту та свої традиції сир та
таки рокам за ціною у вас половиною
тисяч євро за тонну щось україна продає
по три по три з половиною тисячі та
поважаю
сверблять що цінність до ціна пісня
російського імпорту європейських вирубних
і самі з чоловік і нішу коти нові ринки
збуту і не хоче конкурувати в
самодопомоги з української та молочної
камінь
ну так цього добра list of ми їх любимо і
нас люблю що але ніхто нас там не
відсікає цьому нікому 4 непотрібного не
самі не знаю що роботи зі звичайними
продуктами ми пробуватимемо вивчати
таким із продуктами на магате seal the in
the nai з аматі
за раз потенційним і ринком і для
збуту українською молочкою експерти
називають країни азії до африки
китаю наприклад вже вранці вона давила на
постачання aus перспективу реального з
нічного за обсі а ми виходу на
європейський ринок аналітика восени окей
коротким